you're going to learn three methods for
solving these special right triangles 30
60 90 and 45-45-90 first we're going to
do the proportion method then I'm going
to show you the equation method and then
I'm going to show you a shortcut method
they're all good methods it's just use
the one that you feel most comfortable
with and then in time you can learn the
other ones as well let's start with the
proportion method the first thing you
want to know for the proportion method
is you want to memorize these two
triangles so with the 30-60-90 the side
that's across from the 30-degree angle
we call one the one that's across from
is 16 we call square root three the one
across from the 90 we call two now any
triangle that's a 30-60-90 triangle like
this one right here in example one if
it's also a 30-60-90 triangle that means
that these two triangles are similar by
the angle-angle similarity and so what
that means is that the corresponding
sides are going to be in the same ratio
which means you can form a proportion so
for number one what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say 1 is 2x as square root
of 3 is 2 9 now when you write your
proportion you only want to have one
variable one unknown now I could have
also done access to one as 9 is 2 square
root of 3 that would be fine as well the
main thing is you want to match up the
short side okay that's one that's across
from the 30 with the short side the one
that's across from the 30 same thing
here the longer leg with the longer leg
okay and then we use the hypotenuse
you're gonna want to compare the two
hypotenuse so now what you're going to
do is you're going to cross multiply
this is the cross product okay and we
have x times square root of 3 which is X
square root of 3 equals 9 times 1 which
is 9 we want to get the X by itself so
we're going to divide both sides by
square root of 3 those cancel we get X
by itself but we don't want the square
root in the denominator so I'm going to
do is I'm going to rationalize by
multiplying top and bottom by square
root of 3 9 times square root of 3 is
just 9 square root of 3 square root of 3
times square root of 3 is square root of
9 which equals 3 the 9 and the 3 you can
reduce 3 goes in here once 3 goes in
here 3 times so we just get 3 square
root of 3
for our X side right here now if we want
to solve for y ok we can make another
proportion
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
compare the corresponding side so I'm
going to say 2 is 2y as let's do 1 is 2
what we just solve for 3 root 3 1 is 2 3
square root of 3 so now all we have to
do is cross multiply 1 times y is y 2
times 3 square root of 3 is 6 times
square root of 3 so y equals 6 square
root of 3 and you got it for the
45-45-90 you want to memorize this
triangle 1 1 and square root of 2 if
we're comparing it to another 45-45-90
triangle
they're going to be in the same ratio
the corresponding side so we can form a
proportion so I'm going to do is I'm
going to say delay is to the leg so I'm
going to say 1 is 2x as square root of 2
is 2 8 now one thing you want to pay
attention to when you're doing this is
you don't want to switch up the order
you don't want to say 1 is 2x and then 8
is the square root of 2 no you want to
make sure you're doing like this
triangle this triangle this triangle do
this trial you don't want to change the
order right so now we're just going to
cross multiply and so we've got 1 times
8 which is equal to 8x times square root
of 2 which is X square root of 2 we want
to get the X by itself so we're going to
divide both sides by square root of 2
and so now we don't want that square
root in the denominator we're going to
multiply top and bottom by square root
of 2 to rationalize that gives us 8
square root of 2 over square root of 4
which is 2 to 8 in the 2 you can reduce
to 4 so X just comes out to 4 square
root of 2 now what you can do if you
recognize see how this is 1 and this is
1 that means that these two legs are
always going to be congruent so what you
can do is you can say if this is 4 root
2 we know that Y is 4 root 2 of course
you can also form another proportion
using these corresponding sides and
you'll get the same result ok now let's
do the equation method number 2 here so
what you want to do for the equation
method is you want to memorize these two
triangles the side across from the
30-degree angle we call that the short
leg axe the one across from the
60-degree angle we call that the longer
leg that's X square root of 3
by the way square root of 3 is about one
point seven
then across from the 90 degree angle
that's our 2x ID so you can see when you
think about an angle you know that the
larger the angle is in the triangle the
sight across from it's going to get
longer and longer it's like a hinge
right and so what you can see is this
short leg is across from the smallest
angle etc with a 45-45-90 the ones that
are crossing the 45 degree angles these
are the called the legs so these are
going to be X and X but the hypotenuse
the one across to the 90 that's going to
be x times the square root of 2 that's
going to be square to choose about 1.4
so it's about 1.4 times longer okay then
the legs so what we do with the equation
method is if you know these triangles
you match it up with the triangle that
you're given so if we have this triangle
here we say oh I can see I'm given the
longer leg 6 and I know that the longer
leg here in this triangle is X root 3
let me make an equation I'm going to set
those equal to one another X square root
of 3 equals 6 then I'm just going to
divide both sides by square root of 3 to
get X by itself of course we don't want
the square root in the denominator so
we're going to rationalize by
multiplying top and bottom by square
root of 3 this comes out to 6 square
root of 3 over square root of 9 which is
3 the 6 and the 3 we can reduce this
comes out to 2 square root of 3 so what
that tells us now is that x equals 2
square root of 3 oh here's our x side
right here that's the shorter leg so
that's 2 square root of 3 and since I
know that X is 2 square root of 3 this
is 2 times 2 square root of 3 which is 4
square root of 3 so what I'm doing is
I'm just putting the X value in for X
here and I can find out what that
hypotenuse is looking at the 45-45-90
it's the same thing so if we know this
triangle we say ok they're giving us one
of the legs 5 let's make an equation x
equals 5 but if I know X is 5 I can say
when I go to the hypotenuse here oh
that's 5 square root of 2 and I know
that if this is axis is also X here so
these two legs are congruent or the same
they're both 5 so that's the equation
method you're matching up corresponding
sides okay now the third and final
method the shortcut method my personal
favorite what you do is you just like in
the last one with the equation method
you want to memorize these two triangles
and what we do is we analyze it like
this if they give you the side across
from the third
angle that's the short side we call that
axe that's pretty easy to work with
because we just have to double it to get
the hypotenuse okay or multiply it by
the square root of 3 to get the longer
leg okay now if they give you the
hypotenuse that's pretty easy the 2x
side you just have to divide by 2 to get
2x and then multiply by square root of 3
the toughest scenario is when they give
you the longer leg here the one across
from the 60 that's X root 3
you would have to divide by square root
of 3 to get to X you might have to
rationalize and then you double it to
get the hypotenuse so let's talk about
that first 30-60-90 so for letter A here
see the 5 they're giving us the one
across in the 30-degree angle we know
that's our short leg that's the X side
so to get to the hypotenuse we're just
going to double it that's 10 and we're
gonna multiply by square root of 3 to
get the longer leg and you're done
see it's super quick for letter B here
they're giving us the side across from
the 90 degree angle that's our
hypotenuse that's 20 so here what we
have to do is we have to say well that's
the 2x side to get back to the X side I
have to divide by 2 20 divided by 2 is
10 then to get from X to X 3 3 I just
have to multiply by square root of 3 10
times square root of 3 is 10 root 3 and
you're done the toughest one is letter C
here because what they're giving us is
the side across in a 60 degree angle
that's our longer leg that's our X root
3 side so we have to divide by square
root of 3 to get back to X the short leg
so the question is is okay what's 12
divided by square root of 3 well we have
to rationalize it 12 root 3 over square
root of 3 times square root of 3 is
square root of 9 which is 3 and the 12
and the 3 reduce to 4 so that's 4 root 3
okay so that was the toughest part now
that we know the shorter leg here for
root 3 the X side we just have to double
it to get to the hypotenuse and we get 8
square root of 3 and you've got all
three sides okay let's switch gears to
the 45-45-90 now this one's a little bit
easier because these two sides the two
legs the ones that make up the right
angle are the same they're congruent so
for letter a if you see okay this is 4 I
automatically know that this leg is 4
but now how do you get to the hypotenuse
well you have to multiply by the square
root of 2 if you're give
one of the legs or divide by square root
of two if they give you the hypotenuse
oh you want to work your way back to the
leg so here we have the leg we're just
gonna multiply by square root of 2 for
root 2 and we've got the hypotenuse for
letter B this a little bit trickier
because they're giving us the hypotenuse
the extra two we're going to have to
divide by square root of 2 okay so that
to get back to the leg so that's going
to be let's do it step at a time here so
3 divided by square root of 2 then we're
gonna have to rationalize by multiplying
the top and bottom by square root of 2
and we get 3 root 2 over square root of
4 which is 2
so that's the Schlage here 3 root 2 over
2 because we know the two legs are
congruent we know the other leg and
you've got it so if you want to see more
examples working with special right
triangles follow me over to that video
right there if you're new to the channel
and you haven't subscribed yet I urge
you to subscribe I look forward to
helping you in the future math videos
I'll talk to you soon